do you allow a subject to tell you what
shots they want to take or do you say
hey why don't I play around with couple
looks and see what you think how much
control does the subject have over what
you take in vice versa well there the
client so you know they've have that
they have something in mind then you you
know I try to put my own twist on it if
it's you know depending on the depending
on the subject depending on the type of
shot we're doing but yeah sure i will i
will take absolute input again it's you
check the ego at the door if they have
they have an idea that that seems to
work than the app course but you know I
try not to I try not to have them edit
the photos right there you know go
through every single one of them because
you know there's you've got you've got
to have some bass control over the over
the session but ya know I I tend to I
tend to be very collaborative when I
work with people
you